you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast optimizing homology directed
repair results with crisper cast nine
I am Brenda Kelly Kim laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's webinar is presented by lab
roots and sponsored by GE healthcare GE
healthcare continues to be an innovator
in the field of gene editing and CRISPR
cast nine research launching the very
first synthetic CRISPR cast nine guide
RNA solution and now offering one of the
most comprehensive gene editing
portfolios in the industry ge remains
focused to developing the most effective
research tools for their customers for
more information about GES CRISPR cast 9
solutions please visit WWE is comm slash
CRISPR you can submit questions during
this interactive event by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the C e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. John she'll John she'll is a
research scientist at dharmic on part of
GE healthcare and develops research
tools for RNA interference and CRISPR
casts 9 genome engineering he received
his Bachelor of Science degree in
biochemistry Colorado State University
and his PhD degree in cell biology at
the University of Colorado he also
completed a postdoctoral fellowship at
the University of Massachusetts Medical
School I will now turn it over to dr.
Sheila for his presentation hi and
welcome everyone Thank You Brenda for
that introduction and thanks to everyone
for joining us today as Brenda said I'm
a research scientist here at GE
healthcare and today I want to talk to
you
about optimizing homology directed
repair results with Chris Burke s9 for
today's webinar I'll be discussing Chris
forecast 9 and the dual synthetic RNA
approach I'll go into homology directed
repair also known as HDR and I'll do
this with Chris forecast 9 I'll go into
some of the background with HDR crisper
cassadine and then also go into some
examples such as insertion of short DNA
sequences with HDR and a synthetic DNA
all ago and then also an example where
we insert an n-terminal gfp-tagged by
using a donor plasmid okay so onto our
first topic
Christopher cast 9 and the dual
synthetic RNA approach many of you have
likely done a lot of gene editing using
CRISPR cast 9 but I want to describe the
mechanism to be sure that we are all
using the same words and definition
there are three important components the
crispr RNA the trans activating smaller
name or tracer RNA and the cast 9
nucleus the active crispr RNA is
comprised of 20 nucleotides of spacer
derived sequence and 22 nucleotides of
repeat derived sequence as depicted in
the cartoon off to the right of this
slide
each crispr RNA hybridizes to a
transcribed tracer RNA through a repeat
derived sequence found on the crispr RNA
to form a crispr RNA tracer RNA hybrid
now it is this hybrid RNA complex that
loads into cast 9 and guides the cast 9
protein to cleave the DNA target site
adjacent to the proto spacer adjacent
motif also referred to as a pam site as
we all know by now Chris Burke a snide
gene editing was demonstrated in human
and mouse cells starting in 2012 with
several important publications from dr.
sharp NTA Doudna church and zing on the
top right of this slide is an
interesting concept that was
demonstrated by these groups for
by the crispr RNA and tracer RNA were
actually fused together by a linker loop
to form a single guide RNA molecule that
was able to be expressed on a plasmid
since then there have been hundreds of
publications utilizing CRISPR cast nine
system in mammalian cells as well as
many other organisms such as zebrafish c
elegans and pigs and the list goes on
and I the utility of CRISPR cast nine
has revolutionized how quickly we can
knock out genes to address our
biological questions at GE healthcare we
offer the editor line of products that
enable researchers to use cast 9 to
induce a double strand break within your
genome of interest once the double
strand break is generated by cast 9 the
cell can initiate various DNA repair
mechanism a common repair mechanism that
is used by the cell is non-homologous
enjoying or nhej a for short this repair
pathway is often imprecise as it joins
the two broken ends of DNA and formed
various size insertions and deletions
also known as ndele
an alternate repair pathway that the
cell is able to employ is homology
directed repair this repair pathway is a
precise repair pathway that needs a
donor template to guide the broken DNA
back into place
this donor template can come
endogenously from the cell in the form
of a sister chromatid or it can also be
introduced into the cell in the form of
a synthetic DNA all ago or a donor
plasmid researchers have utilized HDR to
make precise modification in different
cell lines and model organisms they are
correcting mutated gene alleles knocking
in large expression cassettes into
genomic safe harbor sites and even
tagging their genes of interest with the
GFP or other fluorescent proteins when
designing a CRISPR experiment for nhej a
the researcher needs decide the source
of caste 9 and also the source of guide
RNA there are many different ones to
choose from so I wanted to go over those
now
here at GE we offer cast 9 in several
forms such as pre-made lentiviral
particles that enabled the creation of a
stable e expressing cast 9 line these
lentiviral particles come in different
promoter options as depicted here these
different promoters will help ensure
maximum expression in your cell line of
interest similar to our cast 9 Lindsey
viral particles we also offer cast 9
expression plasmids that have the same
promoter options these casting plasmids
have the additional benefit of having
the flexibility of expressing either MK
2 so afar red fluorescent protein or a
pure myosin resistance gene with a t 2 a
fusion so a self cleaving peptide with
cast 9 we also have to cast 9 DNA free
options in the form of cast 9 mRNA and
cast 9 recombinant protein when
selecting a source of the guide RNA we
also have a few different options to
decide between utilizing our experience
at making synthetic RNA we are able to
make synthetic crispr RNA and synthetic
tracer RNA I'll go into this a little
bit more detail later on we also offer
single guide RNAs as lentiviral
particles for difficult transfect so
lastly we are able to leverage our
patented chemistry to be able to
synthesize this long synthetic single
guide RNA it is important to say that
any of our cast 9 products on the left
hand side of this slide are compatible
with any of the guide RNA sources on the
right hand side of this slide all these
different choices are important because
as you will see later on maximizing
double strand breaks in your system will
increase chances of getting your desired
HD our modification now when performing
an experiment that will utilize HDR you
also need to consider the source of the
donor template common DNA templates that
are used are synthetic DNA eligos and
donor plasmid again I'll talk a little
bit more about these later when I get
into specific examples utilizing a
single-stranded DNA all ago and
utilizing a DNA donor plasmid
but first I want to get back into
choosing guide RNA so let's discuss this
in a little bit more detail
currently the guide RNA is offered
either as a single molecule vector
Express single guide RNA or as an RNA
based guide RNA that can be in the form
of a single or dual RNA system as I list
on this slide the vector based single
guide RNA expresses crispr RNA and
tracer RNA as a single molecule which
enables enrichment for the sgrna when
introduced into cells you can also use
this sgrna system to perform lentiviral
pooled screening on the other hand RNA
based guide RNAs have transient activity
that do not have a risk of DNA
integration these are easily transected
and can be used performed arrays
screening in 2014 we were the first
company to employ the synthetic dual RNA
approach for CRISPR cast nine guide RNAs
with the launch of our editor product
line this synthetic dual RNA system is
exactly like the natural bacterial
system with a custom synthetic RNA
comprising the twenty to twenty
nucleotide target sequence and the 22
nucleotides fixed s pyogenes repeat
sequence this crispr RNA will bind to
our tracy RNA which we also make
synthetically we believe this approach
makes it easier for the researcher
because it does not require cloning to
generate your guide RNA additionally
with this being a synthetic RNA system
it provides the possibility of chemical
modifications to enhance functionality
and to perform arrayed screens using
phenotypes that are not amenable to
pooled screens now paying attention to
the trace of RNA here at GE healthcare
dharmic on our patented 2 prime ace
chemistry is really ideal for the
synthesis of long RNA such as this for
74 nucleotide tracer RNA this chemistry
provides fast coupling rates high yields
and greater purity than traditional RNA
protection strategies on
left-hand side of this slide is a you
peel trace of our editor Tracy RNA
demonstrating the high quality RNA that
is routinely synthesized by dharmic on
so with all of these reagents in mind I
would like to speak about using them to
perform homology directed repair one
thing to note though in many cell types
in atj dominates DNA repair during g1 s
and g2 phases of the cell cycle whereas
HDR is restricted to late s and g2
phases of the cell cycle when DNA
replication has completed and sister
chromatids are available to serve as
repair templates however even in late s
and g2 in h ej is still active still
competing with HDR and it is often more
efficient at repairing double strand DNA
breaks
now when the CRISPR craze began in 2012
and 2013 researchers were able to
demonstrate the utility of using CRISPR
task 9 with HDR for example ran at all
so the Tarte the chart at the top left
of the screen shows varying levels of
HDR efficiency at different CRISPR sites
and these levels varied between the
wild-type Cassadine and the caste 9
decays additionally rats at all and
other researchers have been able to
knock in GFP tags
under the expression of the endogenous
gene targets and so this is shown in the
top right part of this slide and these
groups were also able to show that the
advantages over these methods over
traditional GFP overexpression plasmids
and lastly at the bottom of this slide
lynn at all were able to synchronize
cells in various stages of the cell
cycle using the kotas all
synchronization and they synchronized
these cells at the g2m boundary of the
cell cycle and they were able to show
that HDR knockin rates across all donors
tested were increased when thinking of
designing an HDR experiment you will
need a method determined
whether or not your experiment worked
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
most of these methods but here I have
listed some of the most common methods
used to identify successful HDR gene
editing the first method I list is PCR
based detection assays that require the
amplification of specific genomic
regions around your HDR target site
junctional pcr requires of PCR primers
specific to the HDR change that you are
making and another primer to a nearby
genomic sequence amplification with this
primer pair allows you to gauge if your
experiment has worked or not a
restriction fragment length polymorphism
assay or wristlet for short requires a
restriction enzyme site to be present in
the PCR product a successful HDR will
either create or remove the restriction
enzyme site and this can be easily
detected when the PCR product is
digested with the restriction enzyme and
ran out on an auger oast gel next
fluorescent reporters are pretty
straightforward you just need to
visualize to confirm the correct
localization and lastly Sanger
sequencing of the genomic region
involved in your HDR experiment will
also allow you to identify if you have
performed successful HDR now I want to
get into some of the details about
choosing a crisper target site for HDR
gene modification you need to consider
three factors when picking this target
site the first one the cast 9 activity
at the target site the second the
specificity of the crisper target site
and finally the double strand break
distance from the insertion site on the
right side of this slide Elliott at all
has performed an experiment looking at
HDR repair events at varying distances
away from the double-stranded break as
they show in this graph HDR repair
events drop off quickly as you move away
from the same HDR insertion site and the
double strand break site at an
approximate 10 nucleotide distance
between HDR insertion site
double strand break site the detected
HDR conversion percent is 83 percent of
the original activity this activity
drops considerably as soon as this
distance is around a hundred nucleotides
and this detected AC our conversion
percent is around thirteen and sixteen
percent with this in mind it is
recommended to balance these three
factors again cast nine activity at the
target site specificity of the guide RNA
and the double strand break distance
from the insert site and these will
allow you to maximize your chances for
successful HDR gene editing event now
you need to design a crisper RNA for
your genomic site of interest by
identifying CRISPR sequences near your
HDR site all the while keeping in mind
the distance between your cast nine cut
and your intended HDR insertion site
also keeping in mind crispr RNA
specificity and functionality and some
of these factors might require a
trade-off in some experimental design
cases we provide a tool on our website
that allows you to input a specific
genomic sequence to identify CRISPR
sequences and design CRISPR RNAs the
link to this tools at the bottom of this
screen so for example I have chosen the
sex 61 beta gene you'll see more on this
gene later on and I have copied and
pasted afford a nucleotide genomic
region where I would like to cut with
cast nine and within this region it
contains the gene start codon and it is
highlighted here in yellow if I want I
can enable a rigorous specificity check
using the enable specificity check check
box this ensures that only the most
specific CRISPR sites will be returned
back to me with all this information put
into the design tool I can click on the
generate designs button and our CRISPR
design tool identifies six different
CRISPR RNAs that are located within this
region I am now able to easily order
these synthetic CRISPR RNAs and move on
to my transection
now I would like to get into the
examples that we have performed
demonstrating insertion of short DNA
sequences with HD RS and a synthetic DNA
all ago
here is a workflow that we use to
maximize the outcomes of our experiments
for HDR of short inserts first design
crispr RNA is in your region of interest
second test each crispr RNA to determine
which crispr RNA has the highest gene
editing efficiency in some circumstances
this can be just more than one or two
CRISPR RNAs
the third step is to design and order
synthetic DNA donor ala goes with
homology arms surrounding your HDR
target region the fourth step is to
optimize your transaction conditions of
your cast 9 your crispr RNA and tracer
RNA and your donor all ago to ensure
maximum gene editing results lastly it
is strongly recommended to always verify
that your intended HDR modification is
incorporated into your cell line as you
have planned it when designing synthetic
allgo donors you need to locate your
gene target and determine where it is
you want to make this HDR modification
in the cartoon at the top of this slide
I have drawn out a design example where
3 blue rectangle shape exons are spaced
out by introns let's say I want to
target exons 3 and here I list the
target region sequence below the top
cartoon on this sequence the crispr RNA
location that have previously determined
to be the best for this experiment is
shaded in the gray box next to the pam
in the red text i've also colored the
stop codon in green that we'll be using
for this example next you will need to
identify the type of HDR modification
that you will want to introduce near the
crispr RNA site two examples demonstrate
on this slide are replacing a snip or
inserting a c-terminal epitope tag such
as a 1x flag tag and you would do this
right before the Jane stop code
we then place homology arms specific to
the gene of interest surrounding the HDR
modification that we want to introduce
another DNA donor design aspect that you
need to consider is the need to modify
the caste 9 target sequence in the donor
to prevent subsequent caste 9 cleavage
in your HDR repaired alleles in the same
generic gene example we need to focus on
the crispr RNA sequence in the pam
sequence the first way to prevent
cassadine cutting is by placing the
desired HDR modification somewhere in
your crispr RNA sequence or in the pam
sequence as demonstrated in design
example 1 so in this design example 1 we
have placed a 12 nucleotide insert at
the end of the crispr RNA sequence
preventing the crispr RNA from
recognizing this site if it were her2
were to occur so the cast iron won't be
able to cleave this site once HDR occurs
so the second design example or another
method of disrupting a crispr RNA site
is by making nucleotide substitution
within the pam or the CRISPR targeting
region as illustrated here and so I've
marked these by purple nucleotides and
also emphasize them with asterisks below
and so this design example is most often
encountered when one of your homology
arms contains the full crispr RNA
targeting sequence next to a pam site
now with all these design considerations
take into account let's move into some
of the experimental data and look into
how to maximize CRISPR cast 9 double
strand breaks the gene for this example
that we are targeting is VCP and the
sequence that we'll be targeting is
shown at the top of this slide the crisp
RNA target sequence is highlighted by
the gray box and again next to the Pam
in red we use different cast 9 sources
for the experiment cast 9 plasma that
was not selected for after transfection
a cast 9 plasmid that was selected for
with pure myosin and a cast 9 stabili
integrated cell line with these
different cast 9 sources
we also transfected in synthetic crispr
RNA and tracer RNA to determine which
method generated the most in delft as we
see in this mismatch detection assay ran
out on an agarose gel 72 hours after
transfection Intel amounts are increased
as we use the pure myosin selection or
our casa 9 integrated cell line over the
the cast iron plasmid transection that
was not selected for now with this
knowledge we wanted to perform HDR with
the indicated at donor template here so
this donor template is 10 nucleotides
that were trying to insert at six of
which create an NH e one restriction
enzyme site so we use this synthetic DNA
all ago and will place 30 nucleotide
homology arms surrounding this 10
nucleotide insert and so our intended
HDR edited locus shown here in the
middle of this slide when performing the
same transaction as before with cast
nine crispr RNA and tracer RNA we now
include our donor DNA template into this
transaction mixture and performed a RRIF
lip assay with the NH e one restriction
enzyme what we saw is that as you
increase the number of double strand
breaks available for HDR you get an
increase in HDR
with the cast nine integrated cell line
having the highest percentage of in
Dells n HDR and so by looking at this
just comparing the t71 data on the left
and also the HDR on the right you see
that the cast nine with no selection and
pyramus inflection and the integrated
line increase as you go from left to
right and the same thing happens when
you perform the HDR transfection so in
our second example we wanted to
introduce an NH e one restriction enzyme
site and the C terminal tag at e MX one
and the targeted sequence is displayed
here we wanted to place this insert just
before the stop codon in green to make a
C terminal epitope tag we performed our
trans sections in our cast nine
integrated line with synthetic crispr
RNA trace the RNA and donor template
again we waited 72 hours post
transfection and played it out single
cells into individual wells of a 96-well
plate and subsequently we singer
sequenced all these cells once they grew
to sufficient size the type of data that
we get back in this experiment is
displayed here the wild-type sequence in
at the top of this slide the intended HD
are edited sequences below that and for
chromatograms
from selected individual clonal lines
are aligned to the HD are edited
sequence the first clone is the
wild-type sequence that does not contain
an intended HDR insertion the second
clone contains an insertion in some but
not all of the alleles you can see that
on the right of this chromatogram is a
clear sequence identical to the
wild-type sequence however once you get
within the crisper RNA and pam region
you start to see multiple nucleotide
Peaks if you look carefully you can
identify the flag insertion the third
clone is an example where all alleles in
this cell line have integrated the flag
tag insertion lastly which is actually
really interesting for us is a fourth
cell clone that contains an incomplete
insertion of the flag tag and actually
has a single nucleotide deletion lastly
we wanted to determine the optimal
homology arm length for maximal knock in
to do this we used our two previously
targeted gene targets mx1 and vcp with
the 10 or 12 nucleotide inserts and so
with each insert we have pinned it on
different homology arm links starting
with 10 nucleotides per homology arm and
then we increase this all the way up to
70 nucleotides per homology arm and as
this graph shows we performed a RRIF
flip a say with that nhe one restriction
enzyme and look cell population and plot
HDR as a percent of the total cell
population so with 10 nucleotide
homology arms we are unable to detect
HDR but as soon as you increase these
arms to 20 nucleotides per arm
you begin to see HDR occur at these
sites you add an additional 10 so 30
nucleotide homology arms you see this
become less variable and then these
results are the efficiencies remain
consistent until you get up to the 60 or
70 or the longer homology arms and so we
were unable to confirm why we had this
drop-off but it seemed consistent with
the literature so we recommend homology
arm links between 30 and 40 nucleotides
now I would like to transition into
performing HDR with larger inserts such
as the gfp-tagged the workflow for this
example is mostly the same as the short
insert workflow except for step 3
here instead of ordering a synthetic
donor construct you actually have to do
a little cloning and construct a donor
plasmid containing homology arms
flanking the gfp-tagged to perform this
we used PCR homology arms of a thousand
nucleotides from you to SL and it is the
same cells that we intended to perform
our HDR gene editing in we utilized
ligation free methods to directionally
assemble our donor plasmid so that turbo
GFP is right in the middle of the
5-prime and 3-prime homology arms we
have designed our PCR primers to the
5-prime homology ends right after the
start the start codon and the three
prime homology arm begins with the first
space normally after the start codon we
constructed one such donor using this
approach to target the sex 61 beta gene
when performing our transactions with
only this donor plasmid we noticed
cytosol like turbot GFP expressions from
the donor plasmid as seen on the left
hand side of this slide to be clear this
transaction did not contain cast 9 nor
crispr RNA or tracer RNA to get around
this plasmid based turbot GFP expression
we monitored the turbot GFP fluorescence
over the course of a week and found that
at day 7 post transaction
turbo GFP expression was less than 0.5%
thus we use this time point for our
future transactions to try and tag SEC
61 beta with turbo GFP in our subsequent
experiments we use so cytometry to sort
our fluorescent cell when performing
facts we first get four healthy cells as
depicted on the left scatter plot
whereby we isolate the healthy cells
away from the dead cells and small cell
debris once we have this healthy cell
population the right hand side of this
slide shows the second gating step that
we perform where we select four single
cells and avoid any clumps of two or
more cells now that we have the desired
healthy cell population we can sort
based off of fluorescence here is flow
cytometry data from untranslated u2s
cells showing gating of this negative
population to separate true GFP
positives from the natural
autofluorescence that can be detected in
the negative population when we look at
data from our donor only control which
is the scatter plot to the left hand
side of this slide this scatter plot
shows the minimal background
fluorescence coming from the donor
plasmid that we previously determined
would be there from the data a few
slides ago now on the right hand side of
this slide we show the scatter plot of
cells transected with cast 9 mrna crispr
RNA tracer RNA and our donor vector and
we see that 5% of the cell population
now expresses turbot GFP but the next
question we wanted to answer it was
whether or not this turbot GFP
expression was localizing to the correct
place we find that sex 61 beta a
component of the protein translocation
apparatus of the ER membrane does in
fact localize to the correct place we
fluorescently sorted over a hundred and
thirty turbot GFP positive cells and
found that 98.5 percent of the single
cell clones displayed the right
localization we further confirmed
this correct localization with
immunofluorescence staining of sex 61
beta as pictured on the lower left hand
side of this slide
lastly we harvested genomic lysate from
a handful of these clonal cell lines and
designed PCR primers to amplify the
region containing the intended turbo GFP
insert as depicted on the top part of
this slide these primers span the turbo
GFP insertion site and if we
successfully get integration into this
site the size of the PCR amplify
increases by approximately 700 base
pairs when looking at untranslated cells
and turbo gfp sorted cells that actually
lost turbo gfp expression after flow
cytometry the PCR band sizes display the
predicted non insert PCR band size of
507 base pairs now let's take a look at
clone number 2 that shows correct
localization of turbo GFP SX 61 beta
here we see an increased PCR applicant
size where turbo GFP was integrated at
all alleles present this was further
confirmed via Sanger sequencing at the
bottom of this slide clone 3 & 4
contains some extra gene editing events
that underscored the need to carefully
characterize your resulting cell line
after performing your desired gene edit
we're saying a sequencing we determined
that in addition to the desired turbo
GFP integration at least one of the
alleles in chrome 3 contains a hundred
and seven base pair deletion that's the
band about a hundred base pairs lower
than the wild-type band as you see in
this gel we found that clone 4 contains
an allele with an incomplete edition of
turbo GFP again an additional band
running lower than the expected size of
the turbo GFP insertion I would like to
conclude with these general tips for
performing HDR workflows with CRISPR
calf 9 when picking a crispr RNA you
need to balance location functionality
and specificity oftentimes you need to
test two to three or sometimes more
crisper iron
do this secondly you need to optimize
your transfection the more double strand
breaks will give more DNA ends to be
repaired with HDR third disrupt your
crisper site in your donor DNA you can
do this by changing the Pam site or
disrupting the crispr RNA target site
and lastly always sequence your
resulting HDR cell line here are a list
of resources that we provide on our
website that will hopefully be helpful
for those looking for more information
about Christopher cast 9 and HDR so we
have various application notes with
detailed protocols and recommendation we
have other webinars such as - listed
here topics include improved crisper
cast on experiments with freshly
designed guard RNAs and also ball a
crisper cast 9 gene editing with
synthetic RNA from start to finish
webinar and lastly we also have a couple
posters as we attend academic
conferences one such listed here where
we talk about designing highly
functional and specific guide RNAs for
knockout and achieving precise knock in
using the homology directed repair
pathway and with that I'd like to hand
it back to Brenda at labret thank you
thank you John for that informative
presentation while we're getting ready
for the Q&A session two polling
questions will appear on the screen we'd
appreciate your answers to these
questions so we can follow up
appropriately with you for the question
and answer session I'd like to remind
our audience how to submit their
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we try to answer as
many of your questions as we can today
and we do have our first question if you
introduce a mutation can you transfer
the donor DNA together with the crispr
RNA or in a different transaction and so
that is a good question and one that we
wondered as we started these experiments
so in our experimental workflows we do
transect the donor DNA template either
synthetic all ago or donor plasmid with
our cast nine and guide RNA all at the
same time in fact now we actually highly
recommend people to do this to ensure
that the donor team template is inside
the cell at the time the cassadine cuts
the DNA target because if it's added
after this cut then it's too late in the
cell can't use that template great our
next question is the cast 9 decays
better than wild-type cast 9 for HDR
purposes so I like using the wild-type
cast 9 this is mostly due to the
increased activity of creating a double
strand break you can use the cast 9 knit
gaze but as many of you know it would
require two different CRISPR sequences
to generate a double-stranded break and
this is where it might be difficult
depending on what sequence you're trying
to target to the sequence surrounding
your genomic target might not always be
efficient to use this to CRISPR
sequences with the cast 9 decades
I see we have another question how long
do the homology arms have to be ok so I
presented data on this and it was a
question we had as well so for synthetic
DNA oligos we have found that 30 to 40
nucleotide homology arms are sufficient
to do these knockin experiment and then
when using donor plasmids homology arm
lengths between 500 to 1,000 nucleotides
have really worked well for us wait
another question what if there isn't a
pam site near where i want to do my
insertion ok well without seeing the
sequence of your intended gene target it
can only provide some general guidance I
do like the insert and the cast 9 cut
site to be as close as possible this is
to ensure maximum efficiency of HDR
however several publications have had
successes with the distance between the
insertion site and the cast 9 cut site
when this is a large distance
in these examples the labs have used a
donor plasma design with a positive
selection marker so this selection
market was either a fluorescent protein
or a different antibiotic resistance so
that they could select for these cells
however every HDR experiment is unique
and so you will have to adapt
potentially a different approach
depending on what your specific
experimental requirements are great our
next question what is the estimated
percentage of HDR knockin with CRISPR
cast nine I think so in our experiments
and just reading through literature for
short inserts using synthetic donor
templates we here have seen knockin
efficiencies greater than 20% of the
cell population containing at least a 1
modified allele for larger knock ins
using a donor plasmid we have seen this
efficiencies drop but they are greater
than 10% when trying to insert a GFP tag
and this is when using an integrated
cast 9 cell line so more regularly we
see that GFP tagging efficiencies around
1 to 5 percent when not using a cash 9
integrated cell population but with that
I do want to caution that we have seen
efficiencies across the board and
they're highly variable in some genomic
positions we'll have much less than 1%
knock in efficiencies okay our next
question how how close should the
homology arms of the repair template be
to the cut site should it be immediately
flanking the cut site or put it be 15 to
30 BP away from the cut site and still
ensure high homologous recombination
okay so a two-part question I'll go
after the first question and then I'll
go to the second so for the first
question I always recommend that
homology arms be as close as possible to
maintain maximum HDR efficiencies and so
leading into that second part it can be
possible 15 to 30 base pairs away from
the cut site and I'll say that we have
succeeded at detecting an insertion of a
GFP tag
to the c-terminus of a gene as far away
as 50 nucleotides but this knockin
efficiency was reduced but we're able to
select for our cell line using that
positive selection marker so GFP
fluorescence using flow cytometry so it
is possible thanks we have another
question if you are using a donor DNA
sequence do you see more consistent
results so the heterozygous edits yes I
guess simply put this is largely
dependent upon your cell line so we do
like the caution that need to know your
cell line because as we all know many
cancer cell lines do have more than two
alleles so determining copy number of
the the gene that you're trying to
target within your cell line will help
temper of your HDR experiment okay we do
have time for just one more question
does Dharma Khan have a protocol for
knocking in specific substitutions yes
so we do have a general protocol or
workflow that people can follow so this
is an applet that we made available on
our website last year so this is for HDR
mediated insertion of short DNA
sequences so this workflow can be
followed to optimize HDR based gene
editing in your cell line of interest so
I'd say take a look at that and then
really just apply the principles there
such as optimizing your transfection
determining the that the best CRISPR to
use and and so on some of the things I
presented here to really try to help get
that HDR editing event in your desired
cell line okay that is all the time we
have for questions I'd like to remind
our audience if you've submitted a
question through the Q&A button and it
was not answered someone will get back
to you regarding your inquiry if you
have further questions that you did not
submit during this broadcast please
email them to TS thermicon at GE comm
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October of
2016 you'll be receiving an email from
lab roots to alert you when this webcast
will be available for
we play we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's event I'd like to
once again thank GE healthcare for
making this webcast possible and dr.
shield for bringing this information to
us see you next time goodbye